okay thank you for your patience
everyone
um well we've now come to a decision and
the decision is that we we're not going
to vary original decision
so we're going to formally dismiss
appeal which means that you will
immediately have to apply the conditions
from the original
hearing but we would advise you to apply
for a variation
well you can argue that our conditions
were too severe which is basically what
you what what you're saying to us you'll
need to supply evidence to all parties
which can be examined
and we are pleased that you do have a
good relationship with GMP and we hope
that that continues
but we believe that there could be a
possibility that there is some form of
movement on the conditions but we advise
you to
do this through a A variation
application
um if you can do this with the agreement
of uh GMP and PC Lloyd and PC Packer and
it could be dealt with as a minor
variation which means you wouldn't have
to come back here
for another hearing to the committee so
it's not that we don't want to see you
again but hopefully you'll you'll take
our advice
uh and and do go to go through that
route which can be concluded fairly
quickly uh with the right intent so
that's a decision I'll just ask Mr Parry
to give some words of advice Mr sure
there are two ways you can make an
application one is for a full
application one's for minor variation a
lot will depend on what what you can
agree with Mr Lloyd and the police as to
the way forward and any of the other
responsible authorities if you applied
for a full variation and you got your
variation in tomorrow we have to the
council has to arrange a hearing within
20 working days of that application
being received so we will be looking
towards the hearing very early in the
New Year if you can come to an agreement
with the police it may be but the need
for a hearing doesn't exist
okay
do you understand that or do you need
thank you
okay anyway thank you for your
attendance
um I don't think there's any further
business
only close the meeting
okay thank you
[Music]